elle a réussi à faire plier à pau
terreur swift avaient menacé de
boycotter le nouveau service d'écouté en
continu qui sera lancée par le géant
californien le 30 juin
au départ l'entreprise refusait de
verser des redevances aux artistes dont
les chansons seront diffusés sur sa
plateforme à new zik
mais elle a fait volte-face ça prenait
un artiste comme tel choix
quelqu'un très connu au fait contrepoids
sur twitter la chanteuse ariane moffatt
s'est réjoui de cette avancée des
plateformes d'écouté en continu comme
spotify ou deezer sont de plus en plus
populaire mais elle ne rapporte que des
miettes aux artistes au canada
producteur et interprète se partagent
10,200 lorsqu'une chanson est écoutée
mille fois c'est une somme très très
ridicule c'est dix fois moins de du
tarif qui est en vigueur aux états unis
des nouvelles plates formes qui font mal
à une industrie déjà affaiblies les
ventes de disques ont dégringolé au
cours de la dernière décennie
au québec près de 13 millions
d'exemplaires ont été vendus en 2005
contre moins de 6 millions l'an dernier
une baisse de 55% et les ventes d'albums
numériques sont aussi en déclin
malheureusement depuis 2014 c'était très
récent on voit déjà que les ventes
d'albums numériques de puces numériques
sont déjà fléchi ce au profit de quoi au
profit justement des services de musique
en ligne pour résoudre le problème
l'adisq souhaite une portion des revenus
des fournisseurs de services internet
soient versés dans un fonds pour venir
en aide aux artistes
une autre solution serait de permettre
la diffusion en continu d'un album six
mois ou un an après sa sortie
si évidemment on donne en écoute
gratuite 9 en même temps pour lâcher des
ventes mais on se tire dans le pied avec
de très faibles revenus en perspective
l'adisq craint que plusieurs artistes ne
travaillent qu'à temps partiel ou qui
est carrément le monde de la chanson
à
ici olivier bastin radio canada montréal